[Music]
how do you celebrate your first grammy
win
well if your beyonce's daughter blew ivy
carter you turn
grammy gold into a sippy cup
one more time because this
grammy-winning young queen is living her
best life
[Music]
this makes me proud blue's proud mama
beyonce
shared this video montage to instagram
wednesday
just days after her nine-year-old's very
first grammy win
blue congratulations she won a grammy
tonight
i'm so proud of you and i'm so honored
to be
your mommy all of your mommies y'all are
my babies
and i'm so proud of y'all on sunday blue
took home a trophy at the 63rd annual
grammy awards for best music video for
brown skin girl
a duet with her mom
[Music]
blue is featured both in the vocals for
the song which she wrote a verse for
and in the music video alongside her mom
and get this blue turning her grammy
into a sippy cup
comes just seven years after her dad
jay-z
famously said during his grammy
acceptance speech in 2014
blue look daddy's got a gold sippy cup
for you
fast forward to 2021 and now three
members of the carter family are
officially grammy winners
beyonce's montage video also shares
glimpses into her grammy celebration
after her record-breaking night okay
wait a minute
history has just been made breaking the
all-time record for the most grammy wins
ever by any female artist
or any singer male or female the grammy
goes to
beyonce
[Applause]
during sunday's 63rd annual grammy
awards the powerhouse
talent accepted her record-breaking 28th
trophy
for best r b performance for black
parade off her blackest king visual
album
i am so honored i'm so excited we see
queen bee posing with her awards
dancing with her man dancing some more
and hugging her savage remix
collaborator
megan the stallion the rapper and fellow
houston native
praised beyonce's milestone while
speaking with e.t
beyonce is a treasure to everybody in
houston
pretty sure to everybody in the world
but specifically from where we're from
we just love
absolutely love beyonce she set a record
tonight how important was that too
it's very important uh as just a black
woman entertainer
black women in general we here we're
here to stay
we're here to take over we've been doing
that but
like just shout out to beyonce for
making her story tonight
you